dear fellow scholars there is a really
fantastic photorealistic rendering
program out there that not many of you
know about so let me give you a quick
rundown of my top seven locks render
features and note that this is not an
official list or anything just my
personal favorite features lacks render
is a completely free open-source
physically-based render many
contributors and it is led by Jean
Philippe Grimaldi what does a renderer
do exactly well there are many modeling
programs where artists can sculpt
objects assign materials to them and the
renderer will run a light simulation
process and show an image of how this
object would look like in real life you
see in a second how cool these tools
really are so now that you know what Lac
sander is let's jump into the best
features hold onto your pants' because
this is going to be good luck render
supports a multitude of material models
matte glossy materials glass objects of
different roughness translucent
materials subsurface scattering metals
car paint velvet and you can mix all of
these together to obtain an even more
complex appearance that's so great love
it
with allied groups you can adjust the
influence of light sources on your scene
without needing to rerender your image
that's the most interesting point so you
can for instance fiddle with the
intensities of the sunlight the light
fixtures and the TV in this scene if you
feel that any one of those are not
useful for the artistic effect that
you're trying to achieve you can just
turn them off instantly and apart from
intensities you can also adjust the
color temperature of these individual
light sources such a gorgeous feature
I have played way too much with this
a great thing about Lux vendor is that
it supports natural rendering it means
that you can use multiple machines that
will work together if they are connected
however what is even better is that this
render offers you many unbiased
algorithms which means that you can do
network rendering but without using a
network now this sounds flat-out
impossible but take a look at this noisy
image not really convincing right now
imagine that you have 10 computers
running in parallel on the same scene
there's a tool called Lex merger which
can combine together many noisy images
of the same scene together better
smoother output so after merging
together 10 images that have roughly the
same amount of noise we get this
note that this is without using a
network so these computers have never
heard of each other we have run the
render on them completely independently
lacks render has sophisticated rendering
algorithms like metropolis light
transport to render notoriously
difficult scenes like this most renders
use path tracing or bi-directional path
tracing both of which struggle here here
you can see the result of metropolis
light transport running for the same
amount of time it indeed makes a world
of a difference and this is the true
final image
different film brands and models have
different color profiles which means
that they react to the same for instance
red light differently lacks render is
able to get you this look which may bump
up the realism of your rendered images
as they will have the color profiles
that people are used to see in real
world photographs
it also supports GPU rendering how much
of a difference does it make
here's a test run after 60 seconds one
with the CPU and one on the GPU I don't
think I'm ever going back to CPU
rendering
and finally lacks wondrous cross
platform it works on Windows Linux and
OS X as well and it also works with a
huge number of modeling software out
there blender 3d studio max Maya you
name it if you like these features
please come and be a member of the
electronic community there is a
professional and quite welcoming bunch
of people over at deluxe render forums
if you have any questions or just want
to show off your work we'll be happy to
have you there we also have a nice scene
repository with some truly spectacular
scenes to get you started there are also
lots of goodies in the description box
make sure to take a look hope you like
my quick rundown and I'll see you on the
other side